la constitución de 1980 establece que en
chile el agua es privada lo que no
ocurre en ningún otro país del mundo
los chilenos pagan una de las tarifas
más altas de américa latina' para
consumir agua potable que en su gran
mayoría es propiedad de empresas
transnacionales
[Música]
lo mismo ocurre con los recursos
minerales la constitución permite que
compañías privadas extranjeras extraigan
los bienes naturales que son un pilar de
la economía del país como el litio y el
cobre pero sin contemplar la
participación de industrias nacionales
ni del estado
[Música]
la carta magna también habla del estado
subsidiario lo que significa que el
estado vigila a los particulares que
prestan los servicios de salud educación
o seguridad social pero no provee
directamente las prestaciones para que
los ciudadanos accedan a ellos los
servicios públicos de salud educación y
pensiones son calificados de precarios
en el país
[Música]
en la constitución está determinado que
cualquier modificación debe contar con
el apoyo de dos tercios de los
legisladores tanto del senado como de la
cámara lo que hace que los cambios sean
muy difíciles de aprobar
gran parte de la población chilena
asegura que es ilegítimo tener una
constitución heredada de la dictadura
por lo que defiende la propuesta de hoja
en blanco que contempla el reemplazo de
la carta magna